all right well we're ready to say let's
play ball right are you ready for home
runs hot dogs Cracker Jacks all that
don't forget your jacket tonight is the
night for you yes the home openers for
the Las Vegas aviators they're hosting
the Oklahoma City Dodgers the ballpark
in downtown Summerlin Candace Charles
has been there throughout the morning
trying to stay warm why is this season
so special Candace
well this is the 40th season you guys
it's going to be a big one good morning
to you good morning folks they have
these a wonderful
new uniforms this is part of it it's
really huge on me but it looks great
still guys and you guys can of course
get some 40th gear here I have Jim Jemma
with me thank you so much for joining me
this morning toast will help people can
celebrate the 40th season with you guys
and how you expect the season to go for
the players as well yeah it's great it's
the 40th Year back in 1983 we started
this whole uh ball rolling but we have a
lot of uh good things for the 40th
anniversary season it's going to be 40th
anniversary t-shirts on our website we
have all their promotions we have Jersey
nights and all that good stuff we'll
have selected Sundays we'll have the
1983 Las Vegas Stars Unis the players
will wear so it'll be neat I know that
you have a few players that have gone on
today it's a few places I've played Nays
before it sounds like it's going to be a
good season they won against Reno Aces
last week they're playing Oklahoma
Dodgers this week how's the team looking
yeah it'll be a good series since the
OKC Dodgers but we have the top prospect
in the a system uh Tyler sodastarum is
that's right first baseman he's really
fun to watch uh Jonah Brides here with
us now he's with the A's last year Hogan
Harris starting tonight on the mound for
us he's on the 40-man roster so uh you
know you never know what you're going to
see even on the on the other team with
the Oklahoma City Dodgers uh we had
great talent in the Pacific coast League
awesome well it sounds like it's gonna
be exciting season thank you so much Jim
for joining us this morning we
appreciate you it all kicks off tonight
the first home opener at 705. take a
start it's at 23 they'll have a couple
of different things going on this week
including fireworks on Friday you can
find out more details on our website
8newsnow.com for now live from Las Vegas
ballpark I'm Candace Charles glavineers
eight news now all right Candace thank
you very much ballpark looks amazing
here this uh early hour uh but you know
one thing we haven't seen but now you're
seeing now is all the food
Vegas ballpark this season oh nom nom
nom new additions the flight deck Burger
which has bacon tomato and onion jam oh
my goodness I saw them play once also
there's a chicken quesadilla now on the
menu it's a also a grand slam Sammy all
on the menu new this year and you can't
forget the burnt ends burrito oh the
best that's my husband's favorite we're
so hungry now